foreign
[Music]
what's up y'all Sean here I want to do a
special episode because the CEO of
twitch resigned today and this is a guy
I got to know well because twitch
acquired my last startup and I worked
with Emmett for a while he's been there
for 16 years he was the founder the
creator of twitch which is basically a
you know one of the biggest Platforms in
the world one of the biggest social
networks in the world millions and
millions and millions of users I think
they have 8 million streamers let alone
uh viewers that they that they talk
about
um and it's a multi-billion dollar
company so probably somewhere between
five and ten billion dollars in terms of
what he's built and I got to sit in the
room with this guy you know every week
for a few hours at least interacting
with them and over time You observe what
is it about these people I've always
wondered like what would it be like to
work with Mark Zuckerberg what are they
actually like how do they actually work
are they any different do they just get
lucky are they just though am I looking
at a lottery ticket winner or is there
something different about this
individual that led them to do this and
uh you know no surprise I think there
are some differences some amazing things
so I wanted to share with you some
stories because at twitch's office there
was nine floors and so at the ninth
floor the top floor there's this
boardroom it's got like 20 chairs and
Emmett would just sit at the head of the
boardroom at the table uh like you know
some Emperor or something like that and
he would a team after team would come in
and they would present whatever's going
on in that division of the company ads
or marketing or whatever maybe and what
he would do is he would sit there he
would talk to that team for 45 minutes
or one hour and then boom on to the next
and so this guy operated at a extremely
high pace and I want to share with you
eight or nine things that I think were
different or special or at least the
stories I remember for having work with
this guy so the first story I'm gonna
call
the birds fly story okay so I remember
sitting in a meeting with Emmett and uh
this team walked in and it was I think a
Partnerships team our marketing team or
whatever and they were super excited
because
um they had just they were like hey we
had this great meeting with this company
they said they wanted a pre-install
twitch on all these phones and uh you
know this is gonna get twitch you know a
big head start in this market and uh
it's gonna be great we're gonna we're
projecting this much growth this much
revenue blah blah
and they were you know they were so
excited they thought they were bringing
in you know this Trophy and um and they
were gonna just hold it up and get
Applause from everybody and and hey it
was it was a good deal but Emmett sat
quietly for a bit he asked questions and
then he um he kind of reminded them
something he said
you know I learned this phrase from Paul
Graham at y combinator
birds fly fish swim and Deals fall
through
like that's what they do deals fall
through that's just a thing that happens
and sure enough over the course of that
year I saw so many teams come in and
present deals that were on the table
verbally agreed being discussed maybe
even signed
and this is exactly even to say this
line and more often than that person was
willing to admit the deals fell through
and so this is something I took with me
which is never to get too high or too
low when it comes to Deals m a uh
Partnerships anything like that just
remember this is what deals do they fall
through birds fly fish swim deals fall
through
all right let me give you a second story
after we got acquired my first day I go
uh up to his office and um I'm gonna
have my first one-on-one with him and I
don't really know what to do I've never
been an employee really like this in my
life so I don't really know I've only
been the guy on the other side of the
table
so I go in
and I start to tell them you know about
what I'm working on and he just kind of
like stops me he's like hey uh
um
what's uh what what's your question and
I'm like what do you mean I haven't got
to that yet I'm giving you the context
he goes he goes uh
uh he goes I think this will help in our
one-on-ones there's probably he gave me
almost like an instruction manual of
here's how you work with me which is
really here's how you work with any
leader any CEO there's four ways you
could frame anything you're going to
tell me number one is hey I'm doing this
FYI just I'm doing this I just want you
to be in the loop number two is I'm
doing this but I want your approval or I
need your approval so I plan to do this
do you approve
number three is I'm trying to decide
between a and b or a B and C can you
help me think that through
and then the last one number four the
last way we interface with them is to
say remember that thing we agreed on
here's what happened it's the status
update of the closing the loop on what
we had talked about and basically
anytime I interact with him that was the
the sort of like the base frame that I
needed to have which was
um
I'm doing this FYI I'm doing this do you
approve uh can you help me think through
which way to go I'm not sure which way
which one I want to do or lastly here's
what happened here's the learning that
we had from it that just simplified so
much and it made our communication so
much tighter in a very short amount of
time we could immediately sync up we
could get through that and then we would
spend the rest of the time just sharing
interesting things or talking about
what's going on in our lives uh because
we weren't wandering around and he's
sitting there waiting to find out like
what does this guy want from me and I'm
sitting there trying to tell him a full
story before I finally get to my point
or my question
um so that was one great framework you
sent me the second one was I wrote an
update once this is point number three I
wrote an update and he just took a pen
and he just drew circles and rearranged
things and he basically said
here's how I want you to write this what
why so what
so that's a format of communication you
tell me what happened why it happened
and so what are we going to do about it
or if we're planning something what are
we going to do why are we going to do it
and so what do you need for me in order
to make that happen
and that what why so what framework
again tightened up my communication it
took away so much wasted energy of
trying to sit down with a blank piece of
paper and figure out how I'm going to
communicate something now I sit down
with a paper and I try what why so what
and then I fill in the details
underneath so that was a great little uh
communication framework that I got from
him
okay number four
he is a fierce nerd so uh this is a
phrase that I took from Paul Graham Paul
Graham wrote this essay talking about
Fierce nerds which is basically his
observation of the best YC Founders so
the most successful YC Founders he felt
fall into this bucket and he talks about
Fierce nerds as people who are
competitive in fact they're often more
competitive than non-nerds right like
typically if you think competitive you
think of a jock in this case he's saying
almost a fierce nerd is almost more
competitive because
they are all in on this they don't have
a bunch of other you know social things
to fall back on they don't have the
emotional maturity to separate
themselves from the competition it is
deeply personal to them and they are
fully obsessed
um he talks about how they tend to be
overconfident sometimes especially when
they're young because they feel like
they can get to the right answer the
fastest
um and he talks about how big a fierce
nerd is so advantageous in the world of
business today and you know so so uh
Emmett falls into this category when I
asked him what he does on on Friday
nights or for the weekend you know it
was like I'm gonna play Settlers of
Catan with the pat you know with the
Collison brothers from stripe and the
founders of Reddit this is what they
would do they would get together drink
beer play Katan I play a competitive
board game or um during our first m a
conversation I asked the Corp Dev guy
after we got out of the meeting I said
how did you think that went I thought it
was pretty good what'd you think you
know is he always like that he is no he
goes half these meetings he's just
playing Hearthstone on his phone and
he's talking but he's playing he goes he
put down his phone he wasn't playing
Heartstone so that was a good sign for
you guys and
um this guy competes like a beast in
fact
I one time asked him I said uh can you
send me
something from the archives can you send
me uh an old fossil so basically when
you started twitch did you ever make any
plans or or pitch decks or anything like
that I'd love to see it because I I'm
just like a I'm a nerd about that sort
of thing I like seeing what people were
thinking at the start because we all
know what it looks like today but what
were you thinking at the start
and he sent me a pit a deck that he had
made an investor update that he had made
right when they pivoted to Twitch
and uh there was this one it was a white
it was no design it was white slides
Black text Times New Roman and uh he
just he was saying here's what we're
doing you know here's why we're doing it
and here's here's what's coming next
um and then on one slide he filled up
the entire slide to almost to make a
point with every product thing they had
shipped and improved that month it was
just full like there was no white space
on that slide and then on the next slide
he wrote
we are we are a steamroller plowing
through a field of flowers I thought it
was awesome because today he's older
he's wiser he's more mature he wouldn't
talk like that he's not like pounding
his chest or whatever but at the time
you could tell like that was that young
bravado energy of
feeling the momentum of hey look nobody
in the honor at that point knew really
what twitch was it wasn't a big deal but
he knew he knew they were onto something
he knew that they were making tons of
progress and I always remember that we
were a steamroller plowing through a
field of flowers like what what a
picture and uh and I love that and I I
since now write that in my startups I'm
like this month I'm gonna be a
steamroller plowing through a field of
flowers what would that mean what would
I need to get done in order for that to
be true and I just work backwards from
that
um I'll give you maybe I think this is
number five maybe the most remarkable
thing of the whole thing
I talked about the early pivot so what
people don't know is that twitch before
twitch uh him Emmett Justin Khan Michael
siebel they were working on something
called Justin TV a lot of people know
this story it was like uh Justin Khan
was wearing a webcam on his head and he
was walking around it's like a reality
show of his life then it became anybody
can broadcast anything which was like
mostly people broadcasting illegal
sporting events and stuff like that like
just bootleg streaming
um and so the site was kind of popular
but it really wasn't going to be
successful because most of their best
content was illegal and they had a
decision to Pivot
at the time Instagram had come out and
Instagram was hot but Instagram only did
uh photos and so the majority of the
company including Justin and Michael and
Kyle they all wanted to do Instagram for
video and they called it social camp and
they pivoted to that and they wanted to
do that and they you know all the top
talent in the company wanted to go do
that
and Emmett had a different point of view
he's like you know on Justin TV I really
like watching these video game streams
it only made up two percent at the time
of of all the content or all the watch
time that was happening on the network
but he's like I like that content the
best
it's not illegal to do so it's the only
good content that's not illegal I kind
of wonder what would happen if we just
went all in and made a video game
streaming uh platform
and he was kind of alone in that so
Emmett went that way
Justin and the others went the other way
and maybe the rejects sort of uh you
know got put on of its team to do that
now social Cam went way up and then way
down and I had this crazy spike in
virality then it crashed and ended up
selling for like 60 million dollars but
twitch was a slow burn just Brick by
Brick by Brick all the way into a
multi-billion dollar company and so the
reason I bring this up is because
to this day
Justin Khan is often referenced as the
co-founder of twitch or the founder of
twitch and I from what I understand I
might be wrong from what I understand
that wasn't actually true he started
Justin TV which uh and then he went to
social cam but like Emmett and his crew
built twitch up from there
um I don't think Justin really they were
in the same office but I don't think he
was working on Twitch actively at the
time I don't think he ever was an
employee of twitch I think it was
helpful and Emmett and Justin are best
friends growing up and you never hear
Emmett try to take credit away from
Justin or more towards himself I've
never once heard him do that which is
kind of incredible
um and so I give a lot of props to that
because
a lesser man aka me would have been
trying to set the record straight and
and say you know no actually it was more
me than it was this other guy who's more
popular than me but uh Emmett couldn't
care less that's his best friend and uh
I think that says a lot about somebody
so
okay that's that's five let me do a
couple more so uh
uh okay if you go into a meeting with
Emmett you're going to notice two things
the first is that
this guy's really really really smart
he's smarter than you and uh I always
wondered this because
I think people like to think that it's
actually hard work that separates people
or it's um luck or it's one of these
other factors
but
it not all not everybody's equally
intelligent uh his oven Burns hotter
like uh twitch uses the Amazon method of
six minutes sorry six page memos before
meeting so basically you write a memo
about what's going on you're right you
basically write down everything you come
into the meeting you hand out the
printed out copy of that to everybody at
the table
everybody silently reads for 15-20
minutes and then everybody has all the
same information and now they discuss
it's an amazing way to build a a very
good culture in your company of writing
thinking and talking uh so it's a great
way to run meetings but the first thing
you notice is that seven minutes in
Emmett's pens down he's on Hearthstone
because he's read the whole thing faster
than everybody else and of course when
the discussion starts he lets other
people talk but then when he finally
raises his hand and says you know here
was my question
it would always be the most on point
thing that would cut to the heart of the
matter and it's like oh why we've been
wasting our time talking about these
other things he's right
you know he he made it he simplified the
six page memo into a really simple
question and conversation
um and so his oven just burns hotter he
gets to the right answer faster than
most people he retains more info than
most people he's able to connect dots
and is more widely read I remember
sitting in a meeting
where we were talking about some policy
you know uh how do we handle this
situation uh streamers are doing this
should we enforce it should we not
enforce it should we change the policy
how should we decide what how do we take
into account what the community wants
and he would you know be like well you
know we could do it like you know the
feudal system in Northern Ireland back
in the 1400s like you know you'd say
some like that and you'd be like
Emmett we don't none of us know what
you're talking about no nobody knows how
the fuel system ran can you can you
explain and then he would explain how
their court system worked and then he'd
be like why don't we do that and he'd
connect these dots and all I could think
about was like I can't believe this guy
even reads about that I can't believe he
knows about that uh his he is he's just
like sort of insatiably curious very
widely read and then you know his brain
has uh this ability to connect data
points in a way that I haven't really
seen since then so his oven Burns hotter
uh I think the people that run these
platforms are smarter and hard working
and blah blah they're they're the
Olympic athletes of uh of business and
uh and I think he's no different
having said that
he's got flaws
so my next Point let's call it 0.7 he's
flawed and he knows it so when I got
there a lot of people would joke almost
behind his back like well
you know and it's all IQ he's no EQ for
me it was honestly further you know
could be further from the truth but I
also met him I don't know 14 years into
running this company I bet if I met him
at year three or four he probably didn't
have the same managerial skills or
social skills or EQ skills that he has
today but he knows what's flawed and he
works on it so his favorite book I think
was non-violent communication uh because
that had helped him so much uh of how
can he communicate with people in a way
that doesn't put them on the defensive
but still gets you know gets things done
he uh only cared about getting things
right not being right so he would use
what I call the Socratic method of of
leadership where when you would come in
you would say something then he would
start to ask you questions and he would
break up your whole argument piece by
piece assumption by assumption why is
this true how do we know that if that's
true then what does that imply next and
he would just go one by one until we
would get to the right answer for most
people it was exhausting and they took
it as almost a personal attack like he's
questioning everything I say he doesn't
just take it at face value but the
reality was I thought it was a
tremendous like approach to getting to
the truth and the truth is all he cared
about he didn't care if he came up with
it or you came up with it he just wanted
it to be closer to the truth to the
actual answer
um he also hired this coach this
executive coach a woman named Flo who's
amazing I think she's like 80 years old
so she's like you know doesn't know the
first thing about gaming or streaming or
twitch or any of that stuff but she knew
about people and I remember sitting in a
one of the exact off-sites and Emmett
has this nervous tick which is that when
he's really thinking about something he
would grab his neck like where his neck
beard was and he would start to like
twist it and it was like to anybody
who's talking to him it's like so
obvious you could see this and it's not
like a normal mannerism people do but
that was his twit that was his tick he
would do that anytime he was thinking
hard he wasn't sure about something or
he was trying to figure out how to say
something to you he would do that
and I loved that and I'd I'd worked
there for maybe nine months at this
point he did it all the time you know
I'm never gonna point that out what am I
going to say like uh you know that it's
just something he did and everybody just
sat there quietly all of his leaders all
of his peers sat there quietly letting
that happen and Flo walked in and she
was like Emma what do you do with your
neck put your hand down you know sit up
straight say that like a leader and she
just told it to him like it is it was
amazing she's amazing but also his
reaction had zero percent defensiveness
he was like oh yeah thanks like thank
you that's a gift thank you for
reminding me uh about that yeah I'm
working on that and um I thought that
that was you know a good sign as to how
do you get better right this guy was
there for 16 years how do you get better
every year well you're surrounded by
people that are kind of afraid to tell
you the truth because you're their boss
and you're the CEO and you're the
smartest guy in the room so I think he
did a good job of identifying his
weaknesses and hiring people that would
literally tell him the truth
um
so those are some of the things that I
picked up from Emmett uh you know Emmett
you had a great run I hope you you don't
listen to the Pod but I hope you listen
to this one because uh yeah working with
you was a lot of fun you know I really
found it fun because it pushed me to be
better I could not walk into a meeting
uh or do my job and be able to get away
with it just on Talent OR Charisma or
some hand wavy that you could
say in a meeting that
if it wasn't for him pretty much anyone
else in the company if I went to the
meeting I could kind of just say
whatever and I could talk my way out of
any situation uh or into any situation
or whatever I wanted to do but with them
you know I kind of felt like a higher
bar was there where I really needed to
have
um the right answer I needed to have the
truth uh because he would not uh his
standard was there and so yeah he made
me better I appreciate that and
um it was a it was kind of cool to be
able to be in the room with somebody who
is you know one of these these rare
individuals who has built one of these
mega mega companies
um and I don't know what he's gonna do
next I think he's just had a kid uh so
you know maybe he's gonna go full dad
mode uh I'm not sure what he's gonna do
but I will uh I will watch eagerly to
see because I know it's not going to be
it's not going to be average whatever it
is there's nothing nothing just mediocre
or average coming from this guy so
anyways hope you enjoyed that those are
some of the lessons I learned working
with uh Emmett from twitch and uh all
right that's it on
[Music]